Hi everyone, in this lesson, we're going to take a look at material optimization in Unreal.
So let's get started.
One of the most important things you can do when building your materials is to make
sure you make material instances.
You can make sets of materials concerning as in parent materials concerning topics
or groups of materials needed, such as say I made a parent material with all the
hard surface items in my environment.
Or I made a parent material for all the translucent materials in my environment.
And then you can control things from there, creating instance materials or children of
those materials.
So to create that it's pretty easy.
You right click any material and you can create a material instance.
That material instance will inherit any properties that you've exposed in that material.
And those properties should show up if grouped properly inside of the instance material
in an orderly fashion.
Now we go over this more in our foundational material courses, but this is just a reminder
of just how important this really is.
It saves memory overhead unnecessarily compiling your shaders and allows you to swap out
textures and values quickly, not recompiling the material continually.
Shader stuttering is a big issue when it comes to making your game.
Some of the things that can help prevent that from happening is one, packing your RGB
into your textures when you can.
And I showed you that in the beginning of our course.
Make fewer parent materials, limiting unique materials with dependencies and use material
instancing as much as possible, which we just talked about.
You also want to manage shaders with complexity such as translucency and not have too many
of those present.
Load your shaders in a loading screen, a pre-catch, and you'll see a link down below that gives
you a bit more information on that.
You want to use virtual texturing when necessary and virtual texturing is pretty easy where
you simply can right click in the content browser and you convert an object to virtual
texturing and it allows you to actually choose your resolution.
Extend your PSO, your pipeline state object, pre-catching with engine features.
So there's a link here that talks a bit more about that using pre-catch and those
features to be able to get things running and going in the right direction.
Here's a link that talks more about these topics.
In the next video, we're going to look at some tips and tricks and some of the things
to keep in mind when working and building your things in your world.
Thanks again.